salut les épicurieuses et les épicurieux
bienvenue dans cette vidéo spéciale
Halloween aujourd'hui je vais vous
raconter cinq histoires de monstres
légendaires et terrifiant et je ne suis
pas aller les chercher de l'autre côté
de la Manche ou de l'Atlantique il rôde
tout près de chez vous la camcru qui
sévit dans le Sud-Ouest la redoutable
ganipote en charrante maritime les
lavandières de nuit en Bretagne
l'abominable petit homme rouge à Paris
et l'horrible craque eu en l'or
bienvenue dans le tour de France des
monstres
légendaires imaginez vous vous promenez
tranquillement sur un chemin quand
soudain surgit une jambe une jambe sans
corps qui se dirige vers vous un œil au
niveau du genou et deux espèces de bras
qui partent du milieu de la cuisse elle
vous regarde fixement d'un œil menaçant
et et elle s'élance vers n à clochepied
forcément ça me rappelle la famille
Adams la chose cette chose c'est la cam
creuse une créature bien connue dans
tout le Sud-Ouest de la France le jour
elle dort cachée derrière les meuls de
foi mais lorsqu'elle se réveille à la
tombée de la nuit elle n'a plus qu'un
objectif dévorer tout cru les malheureux
qui croise sa route d'où son nom cam cru
que l'on peut traduire par viande crue
d'où vient cette histoire probablement
d'un vieux compte à jeunis qu'on se
racontait autrefois le soir au coin du
feu pour se faire peur je vous pitche
l'histoire un jour la femme d'un homme
très riche tombe et se brise la jambe
pour la remplacer son mari lui fait
faire une jambe en or au bout de 7 ans
la femme meurt et on l'enterre avec sa
précieuse jambe quelques temps plus tard
un valet décide de profaner la tombe
pour subtiliser la jambe une voix
féminine se fait alors entendre dans
tout le cimetière dors dors rendez-moi
ma jambe d'or le valet un peu inquiet
demande que voulez-vous madame et la
femme surgit de sa tombe en hurlant
c'est toi que je veux puis elle
l'entraîne dans son trou et le dévore
depuis une jambe à vide de chair fraîche
entit la région en terrorisant les
habitants en 2021 un jeu a été organisé
sur TikTok le Gide de la camcuse comme
quoi le temps passe mais les légendes
restent on remonte un tout petit peu au
nord en Charente Maritime c'est dans ce
beau département bordé par l'océan
Atlantique mais aussi dans une bonne
partie du Poitou jusqu'en Touren que
l'on cultive le mythe de la gipotte un
joli nom qui peut prêter à sourire
pourtant ne vous y fiez pas c'est un
monstre ceux qui disent l'avoir vu
prétendent qu'elle ressemble à un chien
son nom ganipot signifiant patte de
chien il s'agirait plus exactement d'un
croisement entre un grand chien un blanc
et une louve l'animal serait pourvu de
puissantes griffes une sorte de Lougarou
comme lui on dit que les nuits sans lune
la ganipote entrerait les bois sombres
elle s'attaquerait au promeneur en leur
sautant sur le dos toute Griff dehors
elle s'y agripe et les fait chuter et
pèse de tout son poids jusqu'à ce qu'il
périss étouffé la ganipotte peut aussi
prendre l'apparence d'un cheval d'un
mouton d'un bœuf ou d'un porc c'est là
qu'elle est le plus redoutable les
enfant ne s'en méfie pas elle en
profiterait pour les attirer puis les
entraîner dans les bois et les dévorer
cette créature maléfique a cependant un
point faible écoutez bien ça peut vous
sauver la peau elle a peur de la lumière
pour l'éloigner on recommandait autre
fois de poser sur les fenêtres des
betteraves évidées éclairé de
l'intérieur par une bougie moi la
betterave même dans l'assiette ça me
fait peur ça ne vous rappelle rien les
citrouilles d'Halloween bien sûr et la
légende de Jack aux lanternes évidemment
la ganipote est un animal légendaire
toutefois de nombreuses personnes en
charante maritime assurent que leur
grand-père ou leur grand-mère auraient
déjà croisé son chemin ont-ils confondu
avec un gros chien c'est plus que
probable la réalité c'est que ce monstre
a été inventé de toutes pièces pour
faire peur aux enfants un prétexte
plutôt efficace pour les dissuader de
sortir la nuit sans y être autorisé ah
j'allais oublier si vous vous rendez un
jour à Saint-Palais surmer en charante
maritime vous passerez peut-être par la
célèbre avenue de la ganipotte je vous
rassure personne ne l'a jamais croisé
sur les trottoirs ça va vous tenez le
coup alors direction la Bretagne le pays
des lavendires de nuit une légende
raconte qu'il vaut mieux ne pas croiser
leur chemin autrefois dans les villages
elle s'occupait de laver le linge au
lavoir elle le frottait avec du savon
puis le tordait et le frappait avec un
battoir pour les sorer mais en Bretagne
on on raconte qu'après leur décès
certaines revenaient la nuit parmi les
vivants elles signalent leur présence en
frappant du linge à grand coup de
battoir on dit que celui ou celle qui
osait s'aventurer dehors avait alors
toutes les chances de voir sa dernière
heure arriver les lavendières
s'approchait avec un grand sourire en
demandant de l'aide pour le lavoir mais
une chemise ou un drap mal oré et votre
sort était scellés les lavandières de
nuit vous sautai à la gorge et vous
étranglent avec un draam mouillé
même pas peur j'ai un lavelinge je vous
rassure on n'a jamais rapporté la
moindre preuve de leur existence je vous
le rappelle c'est une légende en
revanche on a peut-être une explication
sur son origine c'est l'écrivaine George
Sand qui n'était pourtant pas bretonne
mais berryon qui en parle le mieux dans
un recueil intitulé légende rustique
publié en 1858 les lavandières de nuit
seraient je cite les âmes des mères
infantides elles battent et tordent
incessamment quelques chose qui
ressemble à du linge mouillé mais qui vu
de près n'est qu'un cadavre d'enfant
autrement dit cette histoire aurait été
inventée de toute pièces pour effrayer
les femmes qui envisageaient d'avoir
recours à un avortement clandestin fort
heureusement les temps ont changé mais
vous le savez les légendes ont la vie
dure et ont dit en Bretagne que les
anciens évitent toujours à la nuit
tombée de s'approcher des
lavoir le Sud-Ouest la Bretagne Paris
aussi héberge ses créat de légende vous
avez bien sûr entendu parler du Fantôme
de l'Opéra connaissez-vous le petit
homme rouge non et bien vous avez de la
chance vous connaissez bien sûr le
jardin des Tuileries autrefois un palais
s'y dressait dans le prolongement du
Louvre il a été détruit par un incendie
le 23 mai 1871 pendant la Commune de
Paris ce que l'on sait moins c'est qu'il
aurait abrité un fantôme sanguinaire le
fameux petit homme rouge cette étonnante
histoire commence en 1575 4 Catherine de
micis alors régente du royaume de France
décide de se faire construire un palais
en bord de scène pour cela elle fait
détruire d'anciennes fabriques de Tuil
désaffectées jusque là tout va bien le
problème c'est qu'à deux pas se trouve
un abattoir qui appartient à un certain
Jean lescorcheur un boucher des osseurs
le genre de gars qu'il ne faut pas
chercher avec la régente ils se
connaissent bien on dit qu'elle faisait
régulièrement appel à lui pour se
débarrasser des cadavres un peu en
comprend et ben c'est du joli hein le
boucher accepte de partir mais contre
une importante somme d'argent ce qu'on
lui refuse il menace alors de tout
balancer mauvaise idée pour qu'il se
taise à jamais Catherine de micis le
fait assassiner l'histoire s'arrête là
où la légende commence peu après la
victime serait apparue à com ruderi
l'astrologue de la reine sous la forme
d'une silhouette sanguinolante il lui
aurait confié que son assassinat allait
entraîner la fin de la dynastie des
Valois et que Saint-Germain verrait
mourir Catherine de Médicis or il se
trouve que le château des Tuileries se
trouve justement sur les terres de la
paroise de Saint-Germain loxerrois pour
conjurer le sort la régente aurait donc
décidé de quitter son palais en
construction pour s'installer à Blois
loin de Saint-Germain mais des années
plus tard le 5 janvier 1589 alors
qu'elle n'a plus que quelques heures à
vivre on appelle un prêtre à son chevet
et devinez quoi il s'appelle Jul de
Saint-Germain la légende du petit homme
rouge est en marche et vous allez voir
qu'elle va perdurer pendant des siècles
comme il l'avait prédit les trois fils
de Catherine deédicis meurent
successivement sans héritier mal la
dynastie des Valois disparaît au profit
des Bourbons et ce n'est pas tout ce
fantôme sanguinolant n'aurait jamais
cessé de hanter nos rois de France on
l'aurait croisé au tuilerie la veille de
l'assassinat d'Henri i Marie-Antoinette
l'aurait aussi aperçu plusieurs fois
notamment le 10 1792 quand la foule a
envahi les Tuileries il serait même
apparu à Napoléon en personne quelques
jours avant la bataille de waterlo sa
toute dernière apparition se serait
produite le jour de l'incendie du palais
des Tuileries cet événement lui aurait
été semble-t-il fatal puisque depuis
personne ne l'a jamais croisé on termine
notre tour de France avec le
craqueux c'est pas facile à prononcer
hein j'espère qu'il ne m'en voudra pas
en tout cas en Lorine on le craint comme
le diable les habitants de la moiselle
le décrivent sous la forme d'un vampire
anthropophage une sorte de croquemaine
avec d'énormes mâchoir des dents de loup
et une barbe broussailleuse son truc à
lui c'est de guetter les enfants pour
les dévorer un peu comme la ganipote
dont je vous ai parlé tout à l'heure
toutefois ces deux créatures ne
partagent pas le même territoire de
chasse le craque eu attend ses proies
dans un lieu plutôt inattendu au fond
des puits les petits lurins étaient Pr
pr venu à l'époque où les maisons
étaient toutes équipé d'un puit s'il
désobéissaient à leurs parents et se
penchaient par-dessus la margelle le
craque eux les saisissaiit et les noyai
vous le voyez les monstres ça sert aussi
à faire comprendre aux enfants que le
monde est rempli de danger c'est tout
pour aujourd'hui j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu je suis curieux de
savoir quelle histoire vous fascine le
plus où vous fait le plus peur
dites-le-moi en commentaire excellente
semaine à toutes et à tous pas de
cauchemar et à dimanche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
prochain